[Music]
I'm one of the lucky ones I was in a
Humvee that was hit by an ie D hit by a
bomb those of us that are lucky enough
to survive we get to come here and be at
this museum and do this this opening but
we also have a responsibility to try to
keep telling the story photojournalists
Michael camber and Louis Pulu have spent
much of the last decade creating
unforgettable images of war in Iraq and
Afghanistan reason TV spoke with camber
about his new photo book photo
journalists at war the untold stories
from Iraq at the war photography exhibit
at the Corcoran Gallery of Art in
Washington DC it's a really an untold
history of the Iraq war something that
nobody knew previously there were all
these little pieces floating around
there now in one place for this book
I interviewed 73 photographers 39 of
them are in the book so it's exactly the
stories that they told me the behind the
scenes stories of everything from
battles to the breakups of their
marriages to stories about PTSD there
was a Shia uprising in the early 90s and
these people were massacred and put in
mass graves by by Saddam by Saddam's
troops and the bodies were dug up once
Saddam was no longer in power people
went in they dug up these graves with
thousands of people and they laid them
out and rose to be identified by the
families Marko took this incredibly
powerful photo and he talked to Marko
talked about how mundane the violence
can become a kid can actually go and
sort of hopscotch over over people's
bodies the fighting the actual fighting
in the war is is you know a very small
percentage of the time there's so much
time where soldiers are sitting around
in moments like that they're shaving
they're brushing their teeth they're
sleeping on the ground you know mostly
the newspapers are going to publish the
explosion or the combat but we want to
show some quiet moments that gave some
sense of what life was like when there
wasn't combat happening
yeah that's an incredible photo it's a
it's a Mahdi army militia man he's
fighting against US troops he's in a
window and he's firing a machine gun you
know Zhao crossed lines he went where
the story was he felt like it was
important for the American viewers to
understand the Iraqi point of view and
to be able to understand Iraqis were
fighting against the Americans he felt
like that was good journalism he didn't
feel that he was there to do just one
side and not the other side he felt that
he had to cross the lines it was
incredibly dangerous I think you know
that photo by Ashley the dehydrated
soldier I believe it was the Battle of
Fallujah and there's something almost
religious about it it reminded me almost
of you know some of so many of my
friends were killed
you know Tim Hetherington was killed
Chris Hondros who's in the book was
killed in Libya al Silva lost both of
his legs in Afghanistan you know so many
people I mean I was wounded myself but
not I was in a Humvee that was hit by an
ie D hit by a bomb but they triggered it
an instantly and it blew up right behind
the Humvee instead of under it I wasn't
you know badly injured so some of its
luck and I think you know those of us
that are lucky enough to survive we get
to come here and be at this museum and
do this this opening but we also have a
responsibility to try to keep telling
the story we were told in no uncertain
terms by our leaders that it was going
to be a quick and clean war we were
supposed to have US combat troops out of
there in September of 2003 those troops
didn't leave until December of 2011 you
know - about 5,000 dead the first rule
of war is chaos the first rule of war is
that you make a plan and it goes right
out the window and again we were
supposed to go into Iraq hold elections
turn over the keys and get out and
that's not how it works and we need to
think about that next time we get
involved in a military adventure
my name is Louie blue I'm a documentary
photographer the Durrani kings is a
documentary where it follows me a
photographer
arriving in 2006 when the insurgency the
Taliban insurgency returns and follows
me up and through the years up until the
the surge ordered by President Obama in
2010 the title comes from Ahmad Shah
Durrani and and that the kings the the
royal lineage of all the people who
tried ruling kandahar and afghanistan
from the beginning of time up until
Karzai because look President Karzai is
from Kandahar President Karzai is a
direct descendant of the royal family
from the Durrani kings so it's really
all about history and how history
repeats itself
[Music]
seeing the war for the first time it was
very personal and daily news journalism
didn't feel to me the way I want to talk
about the war and so after my first trip
there I wanted to go back and I wanted
to go back on my own and spend many many
months without answering to an editor
who was in an inner city so I quit my
job and started going back on my own
dime when I arrived in 2010 I think
there was an excitement you know it was
a youth sort of this youthful naive
exciting I had never covered a war I'm
covering just general stuff daily life
and then I cover a suicide bombing a guy
at a vest on blew himself up something
photography does not do is it doesn't
explain two essential things about war
one combat is about sound combat is is
audio it's gunfire it's explosions it's
people screaming it's the sound of flesh
and blood in in the frontline trauma
rooms and it doesn't explain smell the
area around Kandahar City where all the
fighting takes place is surrounded by
grape fields it is about the contrasts
of the grapes and the bullets the bounty
of nature and the bounty of war if you
know your art history when I when I saw
this guy eating the grapes I immediately
thought of a Caravaggio painting
probably one of the most famous
photographs is the world war two photo
where US Marines are raising a US flag
on Mount Suribachi in yo Jima but you
have no idea who any of those guys are
you don't know their names you can't see
their faces you know now here in
Washington DC there's a massive memorial
there's a stamp I want to know who some
of those guys could have been I had
heard the Marines had been redeployed I
asked to go to the worst combat outpost
that they had and they sent me there and
I wanted to do a series of portraits
that would not have a flag they wouldn't
have any guns and they would be looking
out at you you know there's two kinds of
photographs photographs that you look
into and photographs that are
confrontational look out at you so it
wasn't about the flag or the EOG mo or
the event it was about that that person
a person who represents people who are
being killed in the war and her doing
the killing there's a portrait of a
marine gunnery sergeant Carlos ogr well
that for me represents her to the
psychological part of war they joked
around there is moments where they were
smiling when I was spending time with
them but in after coming in from that
not too many smiles going on it was so
hot man
we had fleas I had ticks I got diarrhea
you know I got a pee and I can't because
we're under fire
I haven't eaten you know all this kind
of stuff adds up to you just being
miserable
but somehow you convince yourself that
it's great so I start going out on night
missions and we went out that night and
the area where we went it's a place
called Kolk outside counter city
probably the worst hellhole of sort of
fighting and land mines outside Kandahar
City and we flew there at night and as
we were coming in to land there was a
bomb went off under the helicopter
before we landed we nearly crashed the
helicopter kind of came back around and
picked up the casualty and the the night
vision on the medics helmet had been
broken off in the blast when the
helicopter lost some control and they
turned on this blue light in the cabin
and all I saw was this casualty this
Afghan soldier you know staring at me
and my instinct was to just take
photographs and some people call it the
Terminator photo because it looks like
something from the Terminator you're
gonna do regime change you need you need
to have a plan for a way out and I don't
think there ever was a plan for a way
out of Afghanistan